Welcome,
students,
to the pharmacology of
the cholinomimetics.
Again, this time
we'll be talking about
the indirect-acting
drugs, the cholinesterase
inhibitors. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology.
Groups are welcome.
The learning objectives.
I've put titles
here so that you
can be aware of what
the content of the
learning objective is,
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
The suggested materials
to help you learn.
You can learn it by any
method that
works for you.
These are just
suggested materials. You
don't have to watch
the video if you
don't want to. You
don't have to do
anything except I highly
recommend the practice
questions because
you can test your
knowledge with them
and the questions
will also help you
integrate concepts.
Preparation
materials should you
choose to use them
the review books
have practice
questions in them if
you want to have
a look at them.
And I have key points
for you. You may
use them or not.
The idea is to kind
of organize it for
you, let you know
what you need to
know, and maybe it can
even help you with
your review time.
I've put titles on
each of the slides
to help you know
what the content is.
and a couple
of tables here
that is boiling
it down for you.
So let's talk about
our cholinesterase
inhibitors. Why
are they indirect
acting? Because it is the
acetylcholine that
is doing the action.
The cholinesterase
inhibitors inhibit
acetylcholinesterase,
which prevents
the degradation
of acetylcholine,
that causes increasing
levels of acetylcholine
in the synapse,
which will enhance its
action. So let's have
a look now at the
structure activity
relationship. It is relevant,
as you will see when
we take a look at the
mechanism of action.
Physostigmine is
an alkaloid. It
is the original
prototype. It
has a tertiary
amino group here.
The others in this
portion have an
ammonium compound
here, each one
of them. And that's
important for
the mechanism,
which I'll get to.
Oh, I circled the wrong
one. Ammonium right here.
Edrophonium, that's
it. It's just
this real simple
alcohol compound.
Neostigmine and
pyridostigmine are
the most important
drugs in the group.
They have a
carbamate here,
whereas you may
remember acetylcholine
had a carboxyl
group here this is
in this is a the
the reason for the
longer duration
of action of these
drugs as compared
to acetylcholine
in this boot-shaped
circle i have put the
alzheimer drugs denepozil
is the only one i'm
going to ask you to
remember you see these
structures are quite
different uh you don't
have to memorize them.
I do want to point out
that rivastigmine is
a stigmine, stigmine,
stigmine, and it also
has a carbamol group
that is going to be
related to its function.
Looking now on the
right hand side,
it's labeled
organophosphates. It
has this phosphate
group here and
this is the group
that's cleaved off.
The carbamate
is cleaved off.
Parathione is no
longer available.
It's an insecticide, very
toxic, toxic
to the insects,
toxic to birds,
mammals, people.
Sarin is a gas, and
it is a warfare gas.
malathione is actually
used as a drug
these shaded parts
here are to point
out that mammals and
birds are able to
detoxify this
organophosphate which is
why it can be used
topically as a drug
this is just a brief
reminder of the
synthesis exocytosis
and actions of
acetylcholine Down
here is the
acetylcholinesterase.
It's at the post
-synaptic area.
Actions. Indirect
acting cholinomimetics
inhibit the
hydrolytic action of
acetylcholinesterase.
That's the point.
They inhibit
acetylcholinesterase's
activity, which is
a hydrolytic action.
Acetylcholine accumulates
in the vicinity
of the cholinergic
nerve terminals.
And that increased in the
concentration of
acetylcholine there
can enhance, also
called augment,
the acetylcholine
activity. The greater
concentration of
the drug, greater
probability of
activating its
receptors, both
nicotinic and muscarinic.
Accumulation increases
the potential for
stimulation, even
excessive stimulation,
of cholinergic
receptors throughout the
central and peripheral
nervous systems.
Neostigmine and
pyridostigmine do not
cross the blood
-brain barrier, so it
would be stimulation
throughout the
peripheral nervous
system for those drugs.
The picture here
of molecules in
the synapse. I
like the picture.
Why are cholinesterase
inhibitors called
indirect acting
cholinomimetics? And what are
the effects of
inhibiting the actions of
acetylcholinesterase and
other cholinesterases?
They are called
indirect acting because
they increase levels
of acetylcholine in the
synapse and acetylcholine
does the work.
And what are the
effects of inhibiting
the actions of
cholinesterase?
Well, to increase
the levels of
acetylcholine
in the synapse
by preventing
its degradation.
The subclasses are the
quaternary alcohol,
that's the adrophonium.
I pointed that
out before, a simple
molecule. The carbamic
acid esters, which
will carbamylate the
enzyme, these are
neostigmine, pyridostigmine,
phisostigmine, all
have stars on them.
The organophosphates
that are used
therapeutically are
malathion and echosiophate,
which is why I
have stars on them.
It's essential to
understand, however,
that organophosphates
are insecticides
and nerve agents
as well and
to know their
actions and effects.
Cholinesterase
inhibitors for
symptomatic Alzheimer's
disease are denepozil,
rivastigmine,
and galantamine.
Only denepozil
has a star on
it. You don't
have to memorize
the other two
for this course.
Donepazil is the
first one in the
group. It represents
the group, and it's
widely used called
Aricept, and this
is the one that you
should focus on.
All right, let's
take a look at the
pharmacokinetics. I've
highlighted in this
orange color, this very
light orange color,
the drug
-specific effects.
Class effects are
really the rest of them.
So, know the
class effects
first. They are
administered.
Only physostigmine
crosses the blood
-brain barrier. They
are all metabolized
by cholinesterases,
plasma
cholinesterases,
tissue cholinesterases,
acetylcholinesterases.
Why? Because, well,
that's the target
of their action.
The bioavailability
matters
only for pyridostigmine.
They are excreted, the
water-soluble ones,
through the urine.
Makes sense, right?
The alkaloid, the
older one, the plant
product, has very
little renal excretion.
So now I want to point
out certain features.
for neostigmine
and pyridostigmine.
Large amounts are
excreted unchanged
in the urine,
so there must be
adjustment of the
dosage for patients
who have renal
insufficiency.
We don't want the
drug accumulating to
greater concentrations
than is necessary
for the therapeutic
effect because
that can increase
the risk of toxicity.
Pyridostigmine is
the only one that's
oral, has pretty
poor bioavailability
as you would
anticipate because it's
water soluble, it's
polar, doesn't cross
physiological barriers
very well, but
it is dosed to get
adequate levels in
the bloodstream to
produce its effect.
has a duration
of maybe three to
four hours when
it's given this way.
So it has to be
taken lots of times
a day. And this,
of course, is going
to vary according
to the patient.
And the dosing
is actually
based on the response.
Neostigmine,
only injectable.
Dosing, again, is
based on response.
Androfonium, really,
really brief duration
of action, which we
would expect because
of its simple molecule
and its weak action,
which we are going
to see in a minute.
Pyridostigmine
also doesn't have
a very long
duration of action.
Okay, mechanism.
We're going to
look at acetylcholinesterase
inactivation
of acetylcholine.
So we'll
start with the
physiologic activity.
The ammonium part
binds here to the
anionic site. I see
this cation here,
electrostatically
binding here.
And the other part of
acetylcholine, the
carboxyl group,
binding here to
this usually called
esteratic site. and
it's a serine. So I
want to draw your
attention over here.
The carboxyl group
binds to a catalytic
triad. In this
esteratic site,
there is a catalytic
triad. And so the
drug binds to this
serine in here,
the drug, I mean
the acetylcholine.
Now, this portion
is broken off and
that becomes choline,
which gets recycled.
That leaves the
acetic acid part
here, the acetate,
stuck to the serine.
So either way, I'm
getting ahead of
myself. So water
comes in, and that
will split the
bond. So we have
hydrolysis step
here, and that will
release the acetate,
the acetic acid.
So the acetic acid
will just diffuse
away, and the
choline now will be
recycled. So bottom
line, hydrolysis
of acetylcholine
releases choline,
acetic acid, now
we have our active
enzyme back, and
acetylcholine action
is terminated. And
this is a really,
really quick
thing, less than a
millisecond, just
about intermediate.
I mean, just
about immediate.
So now, let's think about
this a different
way. Okay,
imagine now we
have a drug,
let's say neostigmine.
Neostigmine has
this portion,
ammonium portion,
and instead of
this carboxyl, this
acetic acid portion
here, it's a
carbamyl portion.
Okay, it will bind
to the enzyme in the
same way with the
anionic side, and it
will bind to the serine
and the catalytic
triad. The difference
is the hydrolysis
step, where the water
will come in and
hydrolyze the bond,
but it takes much,
much, much, much,
much longer than a
millisecond. It can
take minutes to hours.
So during that time,
acetylcholine
cannot access the
acetylcholinesterase.
It will accumulate.
Pretty simple idea.
The edrophonium
is just known as a
competitive inhibitor. It
binds electrostatically
only at that anionic
site. and then
it rapidly dissociates
and that's why
it has such a short
duration of action.
The carbonic acid esters,
carbamylate that
catalytic triad site,
the esteratic site,
as I mentioned, and
it takes a lot longer
to hydrolyze it.
The organophosphates
now will phosphorylate
at the catalytic triad
And this bond is
extremely stable.
It hydrolyzes really,
really slowly.
In fact, it's so
slow that a new
enzyme needs to be
synthesized in order
to get the enzyme
activity back.
Now, there's another
piece to this
that's important.
It's called aging,
where that phosphate
enzyme bond becomes
so strong that
it's irreversible.
That will become
important when
we talk about
the antidote.
Now looking at
the drugs for
Alzheimer's disease,
they are reversible
cholinesterase
inhibitors. They
do cross the blood
-brain barrier.
These two, denepizil and
galantamine, are
not carbamates.
Rivastigmine is
a carbamate, so
it will act
the same way as
the carbamic acid
esters above.
Dinepezil is a non
-competitive inhibitor.
Galanthamine is a
competitive inhibitor.
So, dinepezil is the
only one with a star.
So, what you have to
remember here
is reversible,
non-carbamate, non
-competitive, crosses
blood-brain barrier.
There you go.
What do we use them for?
Well, I'm going to
talk about myasthenia
gravis in the
next slide and
talk about the
pathophysiology of it.
For now,
edrophonium has been
used in the diagnosis
of myasthenia gravis.
It is no longer
available, and the reason
is because it actually
is not a very helpful
tool for diagnosing
myasthenia gravis. It
has poor sensitivity
and specificity.
And we have better
ways to do it now
by just detecting
autoantibodies against the
receptor, the nicotinic
receptor in the
neuromuscular junction.
Neostigmine and
pyridostigmine, I'm going
to always be talking
about together.
They are used
for virtually the
same things, except that
pyridostigmine is
the only oral one.
it is used it is
the main one used
for myasthenia gravis
treatment because
of the fact
that it's oral
neostigmine is used
for myasthenia gravis
also except it
has to be injected
they can both be
used for reversal of
non-depolarizing
neuromuscular blockade
So I'm going to have to
mention what
that means here.
I talked about
the blockade, the
depolarizing
blockade of nicotinic
receptors when
we talked about
nicotine in the
previous lecture.
With depolarizing
blockade, the ionotropic
nicotinic receptor
opens initially
and then becomes
overstimulated with
high amounts of
nicotine and it will
therefore become
insensitive and it
will not produce an
action potential.
Non-depolarizing
neuromuscular blockers
are drugs that are
used in surgery
to paralyze the
skeletal muscles
in order to facilitate
the surgery.
They are competitive
inhibitors.
Okay,
thinking about the fact
that non-depolarizing
neuromuscular blockers
are competitive
inhibitors, think
about the mechanism of
reversal with a
cholinesterase inhibitor.
Inhibiting the
acetylcholinesterase will
increase the concentrations
of acetylcholine
and the synapse, such
that acetylcholine can
now out-compete the
blocking drug and therefore
increase the possibility
of creating an
action potential, an
end plate potential,
and muscle contractions.
That's the concept
here with the mechanism
for reversal of non
-depolarizing neuromuscular
blockers, and I
will talk more about
that when we get to that
section of pharmacology
at a later date.
Pyridostigmine can
also be given IV
for the reversal
of neuromuscular
block, and it's the
same concept. Now,
I draw your attention
to this line,
neostigmine and
pyridostigmine again well
we know they are
colinesterase inhibitors but
they also have another
action they are
direct nicotinic
receptor agonists at the
neuromuscular junction
and the autonomic ganglia
of course so anywhere
any place there's
the neuronicotinic
receptor in the periphery.
They would have a
direct agonist effect.
Phisostigmine is
an antidote for
anticholinergic toxicity.
We're talking about
atropine or or gymson
weed, or some of these
other pure muscarinic
receptor antagonists.
Pure meaning that
they don't have
other actions, just
muscarinic receptors.
Phisostigmine does
cross into the CNS,
which is where the
importance of its use is
to manage the life
-threatening delirium
caused by all of this
over-blockade of the
muscarinic receptors
in the CNS. However,
phisostigmine has its
own toxicities. It
can cause bradycardia.
You would expect
that because of the
increased effects on the
M2 receptors in the
heart. It can cause
respiratory distress,
both centrally and
its actions at the
neuromuscular junction.
And it can cause seizures
with too rapid
administration.
So its use is somewhat
controversial
among some experts.
This anticholinergic
toxicity can also be
managed in the hospital
with supportive care.
Let's move to malathione.
Topical only.
It happens to
come in a lotion.
And it's for head and
***** lice and their
eggs. And also for
scabies. Scabies is
caused by this little
arachnid called a mite.
The drug has to
remain on the
skin overnight.
And then it gets
washed off with
soap and water.
Echoclopate is just
ophthalmic. that's
used to reduce intraocular
pressure to induce
meiosis and it's
not used very often.
Let's talk about
the pathophysiology
of myasthenia gravis.
This is an
autoimmune disease.
It is auto
antibodies against
neuromuscular
nicotinic receptors.
On the left
hand side is the
normal looking
neuromuscular
junction and
cholinergic neuron.
We see the acetylcholine
being introduced
into the synapse and we
have various receptors
that it will bind to
produce an end plate
potential and skeletal
muscle contraction.
Looking at the left
-hand side, you can see
the synapse looks
quite a bit different.
The autoantibodies
will bind to the
nicotinic receptors
and cross-link.
it will draw these
autoantibodies will
draw complement and the
complement will cause
lysis of the nicotinic
receptors which
is going to reduce the
number of receptors
acetylcholine is
still being introduced
into the synapse so
what is the role then
of the cholinesterase
inhibitors by
blocking acetylcholinesterase
then their
acetylcholine which is
going to continue to
be released can
accumulate in the synapse,
which can increase
the probability that
acetylcholine will
bind to whatever
receptors happen to
be left, happen to be
remaining, and produce
a muscle contraction.
So now I want to just
mention adrophonium
because it can
still appear on a
board exam and it is an
important pharmacology
concept that we're
talking about.
We said before that
edrophonium is used as
a test for diagnosing
myasthenia gravis.
And the way that
is done is to give
a little bit of
edrophonium, inject
a little bit of it,
either IV or IM.
And that will cause
an increase in
muscle contraction
in the patient with
myasthenia gravis.
All right, we
said that it really
is not a very good
diagnostic tool.
It's not reliable.
So let's talk about
the difference between
myasthenic crisis and
cholinergic crisis.
Myasthenic crisis
means that there's just
not enough activation
of those neuromuscular
nicotinic receptors.
And as a result, the
patient can develop
respiratory failure
because of weakness of
the respiratory muscles
and potentially die.
With cholinergic
crisis, we get muscle
weakness and respiratory
failure because of
the depolarizing block
that's resulting from
the excessive amount
of stimulation of the
nicotinic receptors.
So the presentation can
appear very similar.
I do want to point
out that cholinergic
crisis occurs very
rarely, if at all, in
patients who are
taking pyridostigmine.
And it's not likely
that other people
are going to
be having these
cholinesterase
inhibitors in order to
cause cholinergic
crisis. It's mainly
the people with
myasthenia gravis.
So what do we do?
Well, by taking
a detailed
history and a
physical exam,
then it's possible to
diagnose cholinergic
crisis. If the patient
has been taking a
cholinesterase inhibitor
like pyridostigmine
and the physician
discovers that
the patient has
taken too much,
then it's
cholinergic crisis.
Through the
exposure to the
cholinesterase inhibitor.
Well, let's talk about
the test. If a small
dose of edrophonium is
given, there's going
to be a brief block of
that acetylcholinesterase,
and therefore
there will be an
increase in the
acetylcholine in the synapse.
So if this increase
in acetylcholine
causes an improvement
in the muscle weakness,
well that must be
myasthenia gravis
that's causing this
respiratory failure.
If the muscle weakness
does not resolve
or gets worse, it's
then cholinergic
crisis because of
excessive amounts
of acetylcholine in
the synapse or in
addition to the
drug being available
there blocking
acetylcholine esterase.
So this could, I'm
going to say it
yet again, still
appear on a board exam.
You might see it
on this exam as a
pharmacology concept. I'm
not guaranteeing that.
So you really should
get the concept in mind.
A patient who had
surgery under general
anesthesia
facilitated by a non
-depolarizing
neuromuscular blocker is
administered a
drug to reverse the
neuromuscular
blockade. What is the
mechanistic rationale
for this approach?
I'll let you think
for a moment.
Administration
of a carbamate,
cholinesterase
inhibitor, neostigmine
or pyridostigmine,
reversibly
inhibits
acetylcholinesterase, I should
say acetylcholinesterase,
which
increases acetylcholine
synaptic levels.
And then
acetylcholine now
outcompetes the
neuromuscular
blocker, reversing
the blockade.
A patient diagnosed
with myasthenia gravis
is given treatment
with an oral drug.
What is the
drug? What is the
clinical rationale
for this approach?
Well, we just talked
about that one,
so I'm sure you
got it right away.
Myasthenia gravis
is characterized
by autoimmune attack on
neuromuscular
nicotinic receptors,
cross-linking them and
reducing their numbers.
Pyridostigmine inhibits
acetylcholinesterase,
increasing
acetylcholine synaptic
levels, which increases
the probability
of producing an action
potential, leading
to variable
improvement in muscle
strength. So what's
the clinical rationale?
Improvement in
muscle strength.
Let's talk about
toxicity now.
Exposure to
organophosphates
and carbamates.
I do want to say that
there are carbamate
inhibitors nowadays
that are used
to control insects
and weeds and ******
on crops and lawns
and in forests,
organophosphate
insecticides are also still
available. So we're
talking about acute
cholinergic toxicity
caused by these products.
So let's think about
what's going on
here. we have high
levels of these
insecticides in the
patient's system.
It is blocking
acetylcholinesterase basically
everywhere. And it's
going into the CNS
because the drugs are
designed to go into
the CNS of the
insecticides, the insects.
so we're going to
be having effects on
all of the cholinergic
neurons cholinergic
neurons in the
periphery muscarinic
and nicotinic both
at the neuromuscular
junction at the
ganglia at the adrenal
medulla, the ganglia
both is sympathetic
and parasympathetic,
and in the CNS.
So it's getting this
widespread effect.
So there are
toxidromes. Let's
begin with
dumbbells. there are
others, but we'll
just do dumbbells,
diarrhea,
urination,
meiosis,
bronchoconstriction,
bronchorrhea, that's
all the mucus,
bradycardia,
emesis, so vomiting,
lacrimation,
salivation,
sweating. If you
prefer, you can put
diaphoresis up here with
the Ds. So what is a
common thread? diarrhea
drip, urination drip,
bronchorrhea drip,
emesis drip,
lacrimation drip,
salivation drip,
sweating drip,
drip, drip,
drip,
plus the
bronchoconstriction
and the bradycardia.
All right, these are
muscarinic effects,
but it's, yeah,
muscarinic effects, right?
Now we have nicotinic
effects, and
it's the days of
the week. Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday.
Medriasis,
tachycardia, weakness,
hypertension,
fasciculations.
Oh no, not CNS.
This is ganglia.
Medriasis,
tachycardia, weakness,
hypertension, fasciculations.
This looks like
all those opposite
things are happening.
Remember, nicotinic
receptors are at
the sympathetic
ganglia also, so the
sympathetic nervous
system is activated.
And the CNS,
central respiratory
depression,
lethargy, seizures,
coma.
So muscarinic,
we see ganglia,
CNS.
Death results
from respiratory
failure.
Respiratory failure.
What's causing
it? Central
respiratory depression.
Peripheral.
Weakness and paralysis
of respiratory muscles.
And let's not
forget what's
going on in the lungs.
Bronchoconstriction
and all of that
mucus clogging
it up. So all of
these features
together can lead to
death through
respiratory failure.
This is a figure
from UpToDate that
puts it into all
of the different
systems for you. We
see acetylcholine
as a neurotransmitter
all the way
through the
preganglionic neurons,
parasympathetic,
sympathetic, somatic, CNS.
The ganglia,
postganglion.
Now sympathetic, see
this is sweat here,
sympathetic.
Epinephrine,
this is coming out of
the adrenal medulla.
and then norepinephrine
mainly coming out
of the neurons and
these are all of the
effects somatic the
fasciculation that's the
jerky jerkiness of
the muscles and then
finally flaccid paralysis
cns all these things
that you would
expect to see central
effects hopefully this
little figure will
help you. I recommend
that you take a piece
of paper, a real piece
of paper, and a pen
or a pencil, and see
if you can recreate
this chart. If you
can, you really, really
understand what's going
on with the autonomic
nervous system and
the drug toxicity.
These are organophosphates
that are available
and can cause all
of this toxicity.
Malathione, I mentioned
before, though, is
detoxified by us
mammals and also birds.
Muscarinic, nicotinic,
CNS effects, just
as we saw. Onset, if
it's inhaled, then
it's quick. If it
has to go through the
GI tract, it takes
longer. If it has
to go through the
skin, it takes longer.
The duration of the
effect is actually
going to depend
on the compound.
How do you diagnose
it? Taking a
very good history
and physical.
And also,
cholinesterase
can be measured
in erythrocytes
and plasma.
How do you manage
it? Well, quickly.
First and foremost,
remove the
toxic agent. Remove
the patient's
clothes if it's
on their clothes.
Get respiratory
and cardiovascular
support. Treat seizures.
We do have antidotes.
Atropine and
prolidoxine, which I'm
going to go into
in the next slide.
So atropine.
Atropine is an anti
-muscarinic. What does
that mean? It is a drug
that blocks all
muscarinic receptors.
Given in the high
doses that it would be
given for this, it
will cross into the
CNS. It will block the
muscarinic receptors
in the CNS to
protect them from
overstimulation by the
organophosphate poison.
and pralidoxine, which
is also called Tupam,
which is a cholinesterase
regenerator.
Pralidoxine is a
strong nucleophile.
We see that here.
And we see they're
using the example sarin,
which is this
organophosphate gas war drug.
It has a high affinity
for phosphorus.
in the organophosphate.
Let's go over here.
Here's the phosphorus.
So prolidoxine, the
strong nucleophile,
will grab on to
the phosphorus
and pull it out.
You see it here?
And that's how the
cholinesterase gets
regenerated. It's
just pulled away that
organophosphate away
from the cholinesterase.
Now this is great
as long as it's used
early enough to
actually break that
bond. Once aging occurs
that bond becomes
so stable that
it is absolutely
irreversible and the
nucleophile will not
be able to pull
away the phosphate.
It has peripheral
effects only.
It is a strong
nucleophile. It's
not going to cross
into the CNS.
So we have atropine
on board to block
the muscarinic
receptors in the CNS and
also the periphery
to protect them from
the effects of
acetylcholine, this
excessive acetylcholine,
due to the organophosphate
and it's going
to be high doses
this is a very serious
difficult to treat
problem it may
take a long time to
really prolong treatment
of that patient
this is a must
know the boards
love it but besides
that it is really
clinically
important and it's
an important
pharmacology concept.
So I have a picture
here of the,
it's called the
Atena autoinjector.
It's got both atropine
and praladoxime
in there. They're not
mixed together because
they will interfere
with each other.
But this autoinjector,
let's see, it's going
into the lateral
thigh here and has
to be held down
for 10 seconds, is
going to introduce
both of these drugs
intramuscularly.
It can be used
for the person
affected by the
toxin. It can be
used by that person
or by a buddy.
It can be given
only up to three
injections should
they be needed.
And I recommend
that you look for a
video that demonstrates
this atina.
The carbamide
organophosphate Alzheimer
cholinesterase
inhibitors have myriad
predictable mechanism
-related adverse
effects. What
systems are involved?
All autonomic nervous
system functions
can be activated because
acetylcholinesterase
is the neurotransmitter
should be acetylcholine
at the nicotinic
receptors of
the ganglia both
parasympathetic and
sympathetic. The
nicotinic receptor at the
adrenal medulla which
is on the sympathetic
side. The nicotinic
receptors at the
neuromuscular junction
and the muscarinic
receptors at the
effector junctions.
Neostigmine and
pyridostigmine do
not cross the blood
-brain barrier.
Fisostigmine,
denepozil, and the other
Alzheimer drugs do
cross the blood-brain
barrier. So have
CNS and peripheral
effects, both nicotinic
and muscarinic.
So now that brings
us to the Alzheimer's
drugs. What is
the goal? The
goal really is
symptomatic treatment.
These drugs do
not cure for sure.
They do not stop the
progression. They're
just for the
treatment of symptoms.
So the rationale
here is that
the cholinergic
neurons project
to various
cortical areas.
Neurons control
attention,
thinking, processing.
They span the
forebrain, brainstem,
thalamus, and
they're responsible
for consciousness
and attention.
So in Alzheimer's
dementia, these neurons
have defective
projections that correlate
with these cognitive
decline symptoms.
The cholinesterase
inhibitors enhance
synaptic levels of
acetylcholine, which should
help improve these
cognitive symptoms.
So I've highlighted
dinepazil, since
that's the only
one that's actually
starred. And I put
in bold the really
important features.
Oral, well-absorbed,
one-time daily dosing,
100% bioavailability.
It really goes through,
it's metabolites
through the urine and
feces mostly. Not much
unchanged drugs. So
renal dosing is not
required. And it's got
a decent half-life,
which is why the one
-time daily dosing. And
it's a reversible, non
-competitive inhibitor.
Those are the takeaways
with denepazil.
So what about the
adverse effects?
Well, they are
generally well
-tolerated by people,
which is good.
Patients can
complain about nausea
and anorexia
and vomiting and
diarrhea. We'd expect
these things from
these cholinesterase
inhibitors.
Altered sleep
patterns and vivid
dreams, they are
acting in the CNS.
Now, there are
some potentially
serious ones, and
they may require
deprescribing. I want
to get you familiar
with this idea
of deprescribing.
Patients don't
necessarily have to be
on drugs forever and
ever, And when it
is appropriate to
remove them, we
deprescribe them. And
there are different
methods for different
types of drugs.
So some serious adverse
effects would
be bradycardia.
You would expect
that hypotension
with fainting, syncope,
AV block. These are
all typical effects
of the autonomic
nervous system, of
parasympathetic. And
anorexia, unintentional
weight loss. That
can be very serious.
And most people who
have Alzheimer's,
not everybody,
tend to be older.
So, what PK properties
of Dinepazil are
important in the clinical
management of patients
with Alzheimer's
disease? And then, what
are common side effects
and what adverse
effects may require
deprescribing of the drug?
So, the PK properties
that we think
about for managing
our patient?
Well, oral. It's easy
for the patient to
take and for the
caregiver to administer.
There is a once
-weekly transdermal
option. I just really
scraped over that,
if preferable,
but it's really,
really expensive.
I'm honestly not sure
if it's covered
by any insurance.
100% bioavailability.
So how
is that important?
Because it
produces reliable
blood levels.
excreted mainly in the
urine, mainly
as metabolites.
So dosing
adjustment for renal
insufficiency
is not required.
It's got this long half
-life for once
daily dosing.
Side effects,
nausea, anorexia. So
think about the
drip, drip, drip.
So the vomiting
and the diarrhea,
nausea, anorexia.
Think about the CNS,
altered sleep
patterns, vivid dreams.
and what are the
serious effects
that would
require removal of
the drug, withdrawal
of the drug.
Slow heart rate,
hypotension,
syncope, AV block,
these cardiovascular
effects, and
the unintentional
weight loss.
So here's our summary.
This tells you
everything that we've
talked about, and
here's a chart that
summarizes all of
the various uses.
So thank you
very much. That
brings this
lecture to a close.